quel est votre avis
je rêverais d'avoir une émission mais
tout le monde et moi dans la vôtre est
pas là si vous aviez une baguette
magique un tank débat sculpture ou parle
on parle théâtre ça ça
partait moi je m'entraînais l'autre et
moi qui me croyais vraiment que je mette
de losail en troisième partie de soirée
allait arrêter tous les brillants ça
rigolait tourner mon rêve je vous dis
mais votre rêve votre rêve à la baule la
sécheresse qui m'a changé votre est donc
votre rêve c'est sûr qu'il fera jamais
méchant mais je vous dis un rêve qui est
possible sur ces 8 eh bien non même avec
peu et avec moi comme me dit que ça
pousse et si peu près comme valérie pas
vraiment je mourrai checketts barre
je rigole c'est mon avis non mais c'est
quoi elle pourrait faire un front froid
mais pradère mais si elle comme avec une
bombe de nadal on l'a fait on l'a fait
lafley quand on l'a fait on a tout fait
alors aux merveilleux des trucs
originaux la fois un peu qu à mon avis à
man
on ne fait pas ça sur la chaîne
les histoires du qu'une histoire de
france ont la vie sexuelle des animaux
je vous jure c'est intéressant mais pas
facile de
[Rires]
travailler toujours doris tout comme ça
bah non c'est vrai ce japonais
nom et prénom mais sinon on avait évoqué
vous et moi un truc qui était après vous
nous aviez fait dit là bas je serais
bien vu à la dans la salle c'est en mai
que abena
exactement c'est bien normal mais que la
menace est passé me voir ce que je peux
faire elle ferait bien ça non mais j'ai
pas besoin de
[Rires]
vous avez de 36 ans de glandes
non mais ça arrive à 37 37 et là vous
avez grandi en plus trop palin serait
pas faux voilà c'est pas faux où alors
benhaim c'est ça ouais c'est ça le
moelleux à un jeu moi je suis
nostalgique de l'époque j'avais un
contre sens ouais tu es mon autre sens
je lai et dribblait stress vous le dis
et incantations c'était le jeu le plus
un creux mais animé fera contre si on
peut voir ça me sert à produire moi
c'est tout un contrepoids donc ce serait
pas mal de tenir en jeu le jeune à
contre sens oui j'adore ouais moi j'aime
bien les jeux ou jamais
j'ai très bien quoi c'est le dîner
parfait parfait qu'il la tue et qui est
arrivé en face et qu'elle fait des
audiences incroyable et qui a tué la
casse mais considéré continue à lui
avait super bien il n'aime pas eu de bol
parce que parce que les jeux d'après on
pas mieux fait c'est que j'ai 10 ans
avec ces mots dépassent copain qui m'a
tuer avant l'été on est passé de 45
ménagères vraiment en une semaine à 23
noms des 23 maintenant il pris un bon
aperçu en
tout cas castaldi donc je sais quel est
votre rêve c'est le jeu 1 contre 100
ouais d'accord walo de jeu mais soulagé
mais beaucoup plus à contre sens sur ce
but on peut pas faire un contre eux deux
[Applaudissements]
en plaques et ça ça me plairait c'est
une bonne idée ça je vais le faire ce
jeu je vais le faire jouer à wii ça
s'arrête très fort et vous allez faire
benjamin va le faire non mais je vais
doit pas durer c'est sûr c'est benjamin
qui animera oui mais qu ça va vous savez
très bien que franchement benjamin est
ce que dit la vérité est ce que je suis
un mec qui est ce que plus je juge peut
donner ce que je donne ah oui enfin ça
c'est vraiment fou totalement mais at-on
vraiment autant et des animateurs
révolte - dont je n'ai rien à [ __ ] je
suis tant que je peux faire du paddle et
qui fait
comme ça m'arrange très content et bien
ce soir qu'elle avait dominée
[Rires]
par messi au nom de la poubelle coiffure
ainsi beaucoup parce que valérie
séraline également aux hutus ludivine
retory est avec nos kelli garner souffre
en effet des besoins kelly
et elle va revenir prochainement mais on
est très heureux de voir ludivine et
quand je suis ravi d'être là également
quel est votre rêve de mon rêve de tout
temps ce serait un tel choix vous êtes
devenu tunisien c'est
la
vérité cedrino macias
elle a voulu faire la tunisienne
derrière elle a fait comme ça mais la
haye vas-y vas-y mon rêve ce serait un
talk show à mi chemin entre oprah
winfrey et ellen degeneres ça c'est mon
rêve c'est le rêve de tout cela oui mais
ça n'existe pas ici on a pensé d'achat
le tai chi qui ma gueule ou quoi c'est
l'achat est l'organe de vérité joris ige
divine a été exceptionnel quand elle a
présenté avec midi glissement j'adore ça
gilbert n'écoute moi j'aimerais
participer à une émission de foot avec
vous que vous admiriez avec d'autres
journalistes ou sa balance mais alors
comme jamais pas mes vraies vérités sur
le foot à marseille comme j'ai envie
d'appeler non je mettrais vous avec deux
trois personnes vraiment désolant voilà
qui faisait partie de lancer des
générations du foot j'appellerai les
vieux de la vieille
je mettrai isabelle au milieu
ça balance comme ça ouais et ben
d'accord et battu voir ce que je peux
faire mais voulait pas animés vous je
préfère que ce soit vous qui anime y est
ça fera plus d'audience c'est pas faux
de plus ces news il a compris
[Applaudissements]
c'est la mission gratuit
c'est mon rêve ça voilà quand je réponds
pas mais ces mots là ça j'adore vous
vous avez non plus instructive à
l'animateur vous avez une tête
d'animateurs des divertissements à
l'effet
de l'arrivée à nice ne maîtrise
pas la maison divertissement où le genre
c'est pas porte-bonheur pages et porte
malheur
qui avait démissionné parce que ça
dépend bonheur et welbeck sabbath élue
playmate apatam
était génial
alors vous possédez un format court par
exemple sur la nuit sexuelle des animaux
très court avec un ton décalé et des
anecdotes dont 11
pour moi
vers l'amont ciani alors moi j'aimerais
bien vivre et je peux parler
ta grand mère
non
oui la bouffe avec les doigts encore à
midi
vrai c'est à bouffer avec celle même pas
vrai la bouffe avec les doigts mais on
se le dire on dit tous ici quand vous
avez mangé ensemble bah oui quand même
il est doit encore dans l'oeuf des
décors
ouest et aurait préféré geler matin hier
[Rires]
je voudrais qu'elle et moi par contre
l'avis 3 contient africain
la chaîne pour les vieux l'année volta
moi j'ai ma démission d'archivés parce
que comme ça fait longtemps chez moi que
ce soit la télévision et que je suis en
fin de course donc j'ai envie de revivre
des moments importants de la télévision
avec les gens qui ont vécu ces salles
mito il ya un coup la suite mais ces
mamies toile et n'aura d'effets à z
santé mais non parce qu'alors je
regardais moi ce mythe ou c'est qu'un
projet il ya un projet qui est sur
l'égérie on est certains disaient ligne
que je fais dans les cartons sur ces 8
pour l'instant ce n'est pas encore
complètement signe avec toi aussi je
crois que mon corps dit oui
je te le dis ne s'est pas conclu et
signé croyez pas le mot okamoto teasing
que je faisais ma vie est unique parce
qu'il ferait une émission que j'ai
découverte jeté beaucoup voudraient pas
parler ou l'asean la can est un
producteur et un
produit
par produit producteurs amis il va faire
une élection quoi apparemment enfin ils
sont en projet pour l'instant c'est pas
signé d'accord c'est impossible
aujourd'hui puisque j'ai journée pas
vous allez pas signé chef alors c'est
pas moins de six niveaux j'ai rien à
dire et bien alors pourquoi vous la
ramenez
on venait d'assister à la mort d'une
immense hall
c'est elle et monaco
[Applaudissements]
si vous perdez un petit peu vidé ce que
oui deux amis doivent partir pour les
mandragore
donc on va les présenter
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit
d'avoir libéré très vite
fait sortir infusion
le monde de la magie
pour l'instant on est dans la télévision
mais la magie deux intéressés
donc bah alors donc alors donc il va
certainement après a priori d'archivés
des marronniers sont des moments de télé
oui alors je vous dis au moins à parler
pour avoir mon avis est alors votre avis
la chaîne m'a appelé ils m'ont dit on va
te fait on va t'envoyer le dossier pour
que tu donnes ton avis je n'ouvre à
revoir le dossier incessamment souviens
très bien de dépenses est hâtif un rôle
qu'on aura vraiment à ouï dire c'est de
la merde émission sera quand même la
lorraine sébastien non mais non
aujourd'hui je peux dire c'est de la
merde l'émission fera quand même c'est
l'émission que je regarderai voyez oui
mais regardez là vous qui n'ont
jamais regardé la regarder ce problème a
dit vous emmerder voilà alors c'est avec
des chiens qui peut être tout ça
donc c'est évident simon babre à des
agressions sais pas je vais regarder je
vous en parlerais la semaine prochaine
je demanderai mardi où des spectateurs
également sachez que bien entendu j'ai
dit moi et j'ai dû à la chaîne qui fait
vraiment ce que vous voulez très vite et
ça va vraiment vous n'avez pas dit
qu'avec montiel c'était une belle idée
alors j'ai dit je ne suis pas sûr de
montiel
jeudi à leur plaisir avec mon pied j'ai
dit allez-y seulement est-ce qu'on ne
mettrais pas quelqu'un à côté lui d'un
peu plus juniors
cela dit j'aime bien les duos mois à
travers le sivu des médiaux vous allez
adorer matthieu delormeau
démission d'archivés
également c'est vrai avec qui vous anime
briller si vous pouviez animé à deux
c'est pas mal producteurs vous faites ce
que vous voulez non non moi j'ai animé
déjà avec luigi lui le bon boulot
qu'elle fait elle est sérieuse à l'état
valérie je crois que ça pourrait coller
aussi d'accord moi je préfère être avec
une femme parce que c'est pour le public
qui nous regardent d'accord donc maxime
rapport 2020
bogard mais en plus en duo ça irait pas
parce qu'il est très grand mais alors
petit lui vous savez pas si ils ont fait
dix ans
l es deux ans magie
au bout je serai quoi votre rêve alors
moi je serais incapable de faire ça je
trouve que c'est beaucoup trop difficile
de quoi mettre de d'animer une émission
ah ouais alors oui je serai beaucoup
trop intimidés j'aurais pas le rite je
trouve que c'est un vrai métier je sais
pas j'ai pas de ce métal la en revanche
adoré travailler régulièrement pour la
chaîne et faire des documentaires
derrière la caméra voilà d'accord mais
tu avais bien je dirais la boutique
attention
je suis extrêmement rapide
et symétrique
alors je vous donnais infos médias à je
suis en discussion avec pas mal de
chaînes pour animer et produire une
émission qui saperait la bm v c'est à
dire beauté mode et visagisme c'est un
format c'est très très fort sur cible
j'espère que ce ne sera pas sur notre
chaîne youtube
[Applaudissements]